So at the end of every lesson, I will briefly recap what we talked about during
that lesson and try to tie it into some future topics.
Today, we started off by talking about the central conundrums and
characteristics of AI. This may have connected with some of
your previous experience with other AI classes, like machine learning in AI for
robotics. We then talked about the four schools of AI, and
we talked about knowledge-based AI more specifically, what is it and where does
it fit in with the other schools? Then we talked about cognitive systems and
how cognitive systems are always concerned with human like intelligence. Lastly,
we talked about the overall structure of the course,
which is broken up into eight large categories, like learning, planning and
analogical reasoning. Next time we'll talk a little bit more
specifically about this class in particular. The goals, the outcomes and
the learning strategies, and what projects you'll complete.